I
had an interesting choice I had to make
because I loved Barry and I've been
waiting I loved the way it wrapped up
last season and I was very much
fascinated with what's going to happen
and usually what happens is you you
might get sent an episode
but I got sent almost all the episodes
yeah you got to send everything but the
finale and my pact with my son who
adores this show loves it and has great
taste is that we watch them together and
he has been unavailable and I was like I
don't know and I and also I didn't want
to cram
it was like this beautiful meal has been
laid out that I'm looking forward to and
they're like you know and so what I did
was I decided I'll watch uh one and a
half without my son
um which I did because and and then I
will watch the rest of the season unfold
and I was
I'm just I I don't I trust you I trust I
trust you guys I know that you know what
you're doing but you have painted
yourself into such an incredible corner
and I'm riveted I'm absolutely riveted I
loved I loved it and I love where it's
going but you've put Barry in this
impossible situation not just Barry but
I don't want to give anything away but
these characters are in this position
where you think I don't see a way out
and I'm
just enthralled just absolutely
enthralled yeah that tends to be what
happens at the end of every season is
we'll write it and then it you know
beginning of season three I think my
first day of the writer's room I said
well he needs to get caught
and so you know I think we're writing
towards that you know I don't see how
this can keep going and then we did that
and speaking of Larry David I saw Larry
he was like watch Barry that's it right
I said no we have a whole new season and
he went why
I go well I think there's more story to
tell and he's like but you it's done
this is because he ended Seinfeld with
the ball in jail yeah right right he's
like hey they're done yeah and so
exactly I didn't think about that that's
true jail means it's over jail oh it's
like Monopoly uh
but he said uh but he said uh that he
was yeah he was just you know we so we
have that and so you start every riding
session for season four and this one was
during the pandemic
like the pandemic happened we were two
weeks away from doing starting to shoot
season three the pandemic happened and
when I went to HBO and said is it okay
if we just write season four to have
something to do and then as we were
writing season four we started to go
back to season three and so I see three
and four is kind of one that's
interesting season it kind of like we
kind of it all kind of rolls into each
other but you know season four yeah you
start off with him in jail and everybody
he loves hates him and uh and no one
ever finds the stuff I find funny funny
this doesn't ruin anything but the
opening of the the season is Barry
calling Jing Cousino yes and the first
thing he says was
um did you trick me yeah
did you trick me and also and he's such
like a child he goes did you trick me
and no one has ever laughed at it but me
and and Ali Greer the editor Frankie
Gutman the other we are crying laughing
at house how he's like Homer Simpson can
we say that he's gotten progressively
Dumber he's got progressively
and uh so yeah we just you know it's you
start with him there and then it just
turns into like well what would happen
what would what would you do
you know and you and the character is
kind of really dictate it and so you
kind of walk through all these steps and
you take a lot of
you know missteps you go down Avenues
and it doesn't work and and from working
it started live for so long and doing
this where it was such an immediate
thing what was so nice about the show is
you could create something and feel like
good and then walk away from it and then
come back six weeks later and go what
the hell were we thinking this has
nothing to do with what the story's
about you know what I mean it's more
about this isn't it you know and and
that was so helpful so we we had
you know of two years of able being able
to kind of percolate these ideas and
then even with that you're still on set
going Duffy Boudreaux who's the
co-writer and uh my oldest friend we've
been friends since high school he yeah
he's he's because he's been my friend
for so long you kind of know how it is
where you're like
on set I'm the guy it's you know it's my
show and so people are very nice and I
feel like I'm a very nice boss but it is
kind of like you hear the uh
you know what I mean it's like uh Bill's
here so it's like you know it's like
puns coming up the opponent's cars here
trust me there is none of that here I
assure you there is no reverential or
like oh God
put on your listening ears
get ready to laugh put on your pretend
happy face
uh no but it is that when I show up it's
like oh gee like you know and and so it
is everybody's kind of what and it is
nice to have your friend from high
school there going like well that's dumb
yeah you know what I mean yes or like
why would you I have there's a scene in
this there's a little bit in the trailer
so it always but there is a scene this
season
where Barry is at his lotus in the first
episode where he's kind of at his lowest
point he's in the bathroom and I kind of
flip out in the bathroom that's a great
scene okay very uh very intense very
intense yeah it was hard it was you know
you two cameras I'm directing it so it's
like okay with two cameras on me uh
uh I'm gonna flip out and then we'll
just keep going and I'm gonna hit a wall
and we'll just keep going and um so I do
what I think you know I I do the first
take and I'm feeling
well I really brought it you know that
was really good
the door opens and Duffy comes in and
goes uh
it's a lot of acting dude
I go what well that's why it's called
you know you get into like a fight like
you did like with your friend from high
school like well that's what I'm doing
man he's like I don't I mean look I'm
from Oklahoma what do I know but it just
it was a lot of like
a lot of like hey look at me you know
and he's walked out and so I got mad I'm
like all right let's go again and then
and then I in the scene I start hitting
myself so the action I'm looking myself
in the mirror and they start hitting
myself and behind the wall I hear there
he is
like there you go come on man but he
doesn't have any like you know there's
no reference there's no reverence
there's no anything he's like come on
man what are you doing you know and then
Gavin Klein top our first ID and aita
Rogers our producer they got to that
place too and that's
infinitely how it's so helpful and our
our editors are like that where I go hey
you're not going to believe this scene
we did and they look at it and they go
that's pretty corny bill you know and
you need that you need somebody to say
you know I just this doesn't feel like
the show man I don't know what this is
this reminds me of
um
just uh
one of the times uh that
I think it was the first time Gary
Shandling came on my late night show
we've been on for a couple of years and
we've gotten through the rough spot and
things are really starting to gel and
then I heard Gary was gonna come on
which was just a huge you know thrill
never had met him in person and he uh he
came on the show and was fantastic and
then afterwards he came into my dressing
room and
sort of shut the door like he just
wanted to talk to me and see how I was
doing and and he said to me uh well
how's it you know how's men how's the
staff how are you guys you know
you feel good about and I said yeah I do
I really have excellent people and he
said uh do you feel like you have too
many like yes men or something and I
said Gary I would kill for just one yes
man and he was laughing at that but it
was true that's the kind of family I
grew up yeah yeah there's not a lot of
um I mean people just sort of
uh make jokes there and I know that we
all love each other but we make a lot of
jokes yeah and so uh there's not a lot
of hey I just have to tell you hey your
work really inspires me you know that's
not the yeah that's not the environment
I'm I'm I would be comfortable in just
thinking about it
if I said that to you I was like Conan
you really inspire me yeah yeah so good
I would say how much money did you get
paid yeah where's the camera what's the
joke it really inspired me too the
opposite to nap and inspire you to nap